smell you later queue day here you later
course that made sense what if my ears
were really out to there if you were
gonna look at me so weird like 2 p.m.
sharp as a microphone but this is the
flexible material that they made why are
you making a ear microphone by a neural
audio it shapes the sound so when you
listen back to it it sounds as if it's
actually traveling through your ears the
camera will be simulating as if your
eyes were there and these microphones
will simulate as if your ears were there
360 we are simulated environments one
this actually works pretty nicely it's
just velcro I'm just gonna walk around
like this what's at stake if I don't
succeed my dignity
so far we've created two years which was
taken by a AK of 3d ear models I then
attached to a base tunnel the little ear
canal through for my microphone really
good they're really high quality funny
when you actually look at the ears you
can see the polygons when you turn those
low polygon objects into real-life
objects especially with form 2 printer
it prints out everything exactly as it
is any little edge or anything that
that's an inconsistency is going to
print out and you're going to see it in
the future
trying to make things as high polygon as
possible by the way high polygon for
those of you who don't know it's the 3d
equivalent of high resolution doesn't
take any longer to print them I'm going
to just be taking apart these little
laws just going straight down to the raw
microphone itself shot a lot of
first-person videos but very
infrequently do we actually ever use the
audio from the GoPro itself it's just
not really created to capture the audio
of a scene if this actually works out
pretty well it's going to completely
change how we filmed first-person videos
it's got a little toast
Bluetooth audio or 1500 music dude
that's all that's all I can listen to
now
all right cool three 15 minutes if you
want to hear this in the best conditions
definitely put headphones on its going
to make a huge difference
we're here in Little Tokyo might be
wondering hey who's wearing the rig well
it's Carmichael he's wearing the ring I
think this is a pretty good example of
the audio here half a minute
I mean maybe I'll walk around here so
basically he's got the two ears on and
you're probably able to hear the
difference right so I noticed in the
comments a lot of people were very
curious why we were making these ears
it's talking a lot about the shape of
the ear and why that's important the
point here isn't you know how we're
reproducing the audio it's how we're
capturing it and that's what makes this
important reproducing the audio comes
through a variety of ways already
headphones we have speakers we're
talking about that capturing of that
audio if you're just going to put two
tubes on the sides of your ears you'd
probably hear a very big difference here
what we're cupping we're coming to the
side of the left ear here and you can
hear
that's shaping the audio and was as we
pull our hands away it starts to sound a
little bit different that's just a small
example of how the shape of your
microphone or the shape of how you're
capturing it really does affect
one of this is the more accurately
capture audio from the human ear for
human perspective if we're shooting a
first-person video like the one we're
shooting right now
suddenly the audio and the sound we're
getting a lot more true to life airsoft
videos if you guys see our stuff on node
very frequently you can imagine it with
a lot more intensive audio like this we
can make a big difference
I hear you're into ASMR this is not
mathematically correct or biologically
correct or anything but everyone has a
different shaped head and different
shape to your think I'll average out
into something right here goes nothing
get it